okay this is very serious Donald Trump
is just making stuff up about the raid
that led to the death by suicide of Isis
leader Abu Bakr al-baghdadi Donald Trump
has told a whole bunch of different lies
about it specific ones general lies like
lie by implication where Donald Trump
was golfing at the time of the raid but
later staged a picture in the Situation
Room about 95 minutes later to make it
seem as though he was there squinting in
the way that I really only have seen
Donald Trump do which I think he thinks
makes him look strong there have been
all sorts of different lies and
deceptions but Donald Trump also aside
from barely being able to pronounce Abu
Bakr al-baghdadi 's name during that
post raid speech that he gave he said
some things that are leaving Trump
administration officials wondering where
the hell did Donald Trump get that let's
take a look at the video last night the
United States brought the world's number
one terrorist leader to justice Abu
Bakar al Baghdadi is dead no personnel
were lost in the operation well a large
number of Baghdadi's fighters and
companions were killed with him he died
after running into a dead-end tunnel
whimpering and crying and screaming all
the way the compound had been cleared by
this time with people either
surrendering or being shot and killed
eleven young children were moved out of
the house and are uninjured the only
ones remaining were Baghdady in the
tunnel and he had dragged three of his
young children with him they were led to
certain death he reached the end of the
tunnel as our dogs chased him down he
ignited his vest killing himself and the
three children
his body was mutilated by the blast the
tunnel had caved in on it in addition
but test results gave certain immediate
and totally positive identification it
was him there's a lot there that Trump
administration officials have no idea
where Trump got it Donald Trump says
that Abu Bakr al-baghdadi died
whimpering crying and screaming Donald
Trump was not given audio of the
incident we now know that Donald Trump
had overhead surveillance footage
without audio how does he know that
al-baghdadi was whimpering crying and
screaming despite the fact that Trump
had no audio and it allegedly took place
in a tunnel and Trump had overhead video
well the answer is he doesn't know that
it's a lie it is just a straight-up
bold-faced lie and immediately when
Donald Trump said this staffers started
messaging it shot each other asking
where did Donald Trump get this about
whimpering crying and screaming nobody
knew so then Donald Trump was asked
about it and he just insisted he's
telling the truth but these are lies
Donald Trump's saying he doesn't want to
talk about it but then repeats the exact
same lies I don't want to talk about it
but he was screaming crying and
whimpering and he was scared out of his
mind and think of James Foley think of
Kayla think of the things he did to
Kayla what he did to Foley and so many
others and for those people that say oh
isn't this a little violent think of how
many times have you seen men I think in
all cases men for the most part but in
terms of this will you see the orange
suits you don't want to talk about it
but then you repeat the same lies then
Donald Trump goes off into other
tangents after repeating the same lies
to sort of try to change the subject
this is a reality of
Trump's own construction that exists
only in the mind of Donald Trump
reporters went to the Pentagon to try to
confirm some of this the Pentagon said
we don't have those details and they
shut their mouths the next day the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
said I don't have that information maybe
Donald Trump has other information check
it out
president Trump described yesterday
Baghdady whimpering and crying before he
died can you elaborate or confirm those
details I said I was that same question
yesterday I know the president had
planned to talk down to unit and unit
members but I don't know what the source
of that was there but I assume it was
talking directly to unit community yep I
have no idea where Donald Trump got that
but I don't know I guess he must have
talked to someone so it's really
important that we on the Left take a
rational balanced approach on this issue
Isis is horrible they are terrorists
losing their leader hurts Isis to some
degree that's good this was not a good
person the world is better off with this
person not alive and to some degree even
if temporarily it damages Isis now that
being said Donald Trump is number one
overstating his role in this entire
thing
number two was golfing at the time but
later staged a picture of himself in the
Situation Room that is a form of lying
number three
Trump is overstating the importance of
killing one leader when you really
aren't doing anything to root out the
ideology that inspires the terrorists
and in fact you may further inspire more
people to become radicalized merely by
killing someone putative Lior ostensibly
known as the leader of the organization
and number four we learned that he's
also lying about details like claiming
that Abu Bakr al-baghdadi was whimpering
crying and screaming something that
Donald Trump couldn't have possibly
known and that no one is willing to
corroborate this is not how we should be
operating even mixed in with the
accomplishments that are implicit in
taking out the leader of such a terrible
terrorist organization the way that this
is being handled is riddled with
embarrassment the world over even
Trump's own staffers are saying
yeah we don't know where he's coming up
with this stuff it is yet another one of
these horrible toxic embarrassments and
there was a very interesting video done
yesterday that compared and contrasted
the way Barack Obama handled the killing
of Osama bin Laden compared with how
Donald Trump has handled the death by
suicide of Abu Bakr al-baghdadi and it's
not about you know every every president
does things in particularly in foreign
policy that progressives would be
against that's no different with Barack
Obama the drone policy we've got a long
list of stuff but after being
desensitized to trump for almost three
years now to go back and see how a
normal person handled the killing of a
terrorist and to compare it to trump
it's stunning stunning how far we've
fallen and it's to call it anything
other than depressing seems to be sort
of missing the the promotes prominent
feeling that I'm experiencing when I see
this this stuff